les excuses arrive 106 ans après la
formation de ce bataillon d'hommes noirs
déterminé à servir pendant la première
guerre mondiale malgré les préjugés et
le racisme
je suis ici aujourd'hui
afin d'offrir les excuses du
gouvernement du canada
pour la façon horrible
donc c'est patriotes ont été traités à
l'époque l'armée canadienne était
réfractaire à enrôler des noirs
presque tous les volontaires venant des
communautés noires
se sont vus refuser l'honneur de servir
leur pays environ 600 hommes
d'ascendance africaine qui provenait du
canada des états unis et des antilles
était déterminé à surmonter le racisme
pour contribuer à l'effort du canada
pendant la première guerre mondiale en
1916 le 2ème bataillon est créée en
nouvelle écosse c'était la première
unité à rassembler des hommes noirs mais
elle était ségrégué et on refusait de
l'envoyer combattre en raison des
préjugés racistes de l'époque les
recrues étaient basés à pictou et à
truro en nouvelle écosse est aussi à
windsor en ontario avant leur départ
pour l'europe en 1917
les bataillons a surtout servi aux côtés
du corps forestier canadien dans le jura
en france et à ravitailler le front en
bois et à effectuer d'autres tâches de
soutien comme la construction de routes
et l'entretien de voies ferrées le
bataillon a été dissous en 1920 of gamer
mais j'aime ce sport comme vdn à leur
retour au canada ses hommes n'ont pas
été reçu en héros
ils n'ont pas reçu les honneurs qu'ils
méritaient souligne le député fédéral
grid fergus
l'hommage l'avait rendu un siècle plus
tard les dignitaires se sont adressés
aux parents et aux descendants des
membres de ce bataillon j'exprime ma
profonde gratitude aux hommes qui ont
servi le 2ème bataillon de construction
je reconnais également
des épreuves qu'ont vécu leur famille et
leurs descendants le centre culturel
noir de la nouvelle écosse a remercié le
premier ministre pour ses excuses de
tiger woods qui fait
si c'était pas ni blanchet radio canada
à halifax
[Musique]